翻訳: Makoto Ueda
校正: Yuri Ueda
皆さんは
宇宙に行ってみたい
そう思ったことはないですか？
きっと一度くらい 宇宙に行ってみたい
そう思ったことが
あるんじゃないでしょうか
しかし 宇宙というのは 非常に過酷な環境で
我々人間は 宇宙服なしでは
生きていけないんです
真空　放射線　熱環境
どれをとっても 我々人間には
厳しい環境です
私には ４歳の息子がいます
２歳のときに「大きくなったら何になりたい？」
と聞いたら
「宇宙飛行士」と 言いました
４歳のいま 「何になりたい？」
と聞いたら
「バスの運転手」 と言います
(笑)
「あれ 宇宙（飛行士）は？」
と聞いたら
「宇宙は 怖いから嫌だ―
宇宙服に穴が開いたら
死んじゃうから嫌だ」 と言って
早くも宇宙に行く夢を
あきらめました　（笑）
よく寝る前に
宇宙の話をするんですけれども
「宇宙はね 空気がないから
息ができないんだよ」
「おしっこだって ばーっと
飛んでっちゃうんだよ」
「太陽にあたると 大火傷して
目が見えなくなるんだよ」
ちょっと刺激が強すぎたかもしれません
（笑）
しかし それくらい宇宙というのは
過酷な環境です
逆に言うとですね
私たちが 住んでいるこの地球が
いかに守られている場所か というのを
感じずにはおれません
もちろん 私たちは地球で生まれたので
それは当たり前じゃないかと
思うかもしれないんですけど
じゃあ 逆に想像してみてください
もし地球に
これ以上 住めなくなったら
どうしますか？
今 普通に皆さん 息を吸っています
この新鮮な空気が
お金をいくら積んでも 吸えなくなってしまう
あるいは 外に出ようにも
紫外線があまりにも強すぎて 出れない
出ようと思うと 長い手袋をして
深いサンバイザーをかぶって―
そういう人もすでに何人かいますけれど
それが標準スタイルになってくる とか
あるいは「ご飯 食べに行こうよ」
と言っても
そもそも 食べるお店も
食べるものもない
そんな時代が来たら どうしますか？
私は 高校生３年生の時に
テレビのパネルディスカッションで
「地球には あと100年後には
住めなくなる」
そう言って議論しているのを見ました
人口爆発　大気汚染
オゾン層の破壊　エネルギーの枯渇
いわゆる 環境問題というやつです
それで 私は高校三年生
ちょうど将来何になろうかと
思っていた時です
それまでは 実は
漫画家を目指していたんですけれども
面白い漫画が描けない
もうやめようって
思っていた時期もあったので
私は 「そうだ 環境問題こそが
自分が生涯をかけて 取り組むべき課題だ」
と思いました
そして そのパネラーの一人
なんですけれども
宇宙科学者の人がいて
火星移住計画というのを
話していました
もともと私は 宇宙好き
もっというと 火星好きということもあって
「あ それだ！
地球を捨てて 火星に行けばいいんだ！
あ なんて合理的なんだろう
そうすれば 環境問題が一気に解決する」
そう思って 私は宇宙開発を志しました
そして 大学４年生になって
卒業論文のテーマが 「人工衛星の熱制御」
これは温度を コントロールすることです
それで 私はもともと
宇宙って熱いのか 寒いのか
それさえ わかっていなかったので
非常に興味深く 思いました
せっかくなんで皆さんにも
聞きたいんですけれど
宇宙は 熱いでしょうか 寒いでしょうか？
想像してみてください
太陽は5500度の灼熱
一方 日陰に入ると
マイナス270度の極寒環境
こんな中 我々人間が存在しえたとして
一糸まとわぬ姿で
地球の周りを ぐるぐる回っていたとします
一体 何度になるんでしょう？
ちょっと簡単に見積もると
平均温度が
太陽が当たる時で70度
そして 日陰に入ると一気に
マイナス100度まで下がります
つまり宇宙は我々人間にとって
時には熱く
そして時には冷たい
そんな環境です
人工衛星もまたこの厳しい
熱環境の中で
生き抜かなければなりません
それが熱制御技術です
それで 様々な工夫が
人工衛星にはされています
その中で
一つだけ ルールがあります
それはですね 電気を可能な限り
使わないということです
それはなぜか というと
人工衛星というのは太陽電池パネル―
両方についてる
太陽電池パネルで発電します
これは「はやぶさ」 という衛星ですが
ここで発電できる電力は
わずかドライヤー２個分です
その中で やりくりしなきゃいけないので
熱制御には できるだけ電気を使わない―
これをパッシブな技術 というんですけれども
パッシブであるということが
重要になってきます
そこの中で 私が非常に興味をもった技術
それが 「ヒートパイプ」と 「熱電発電」
という技術です
これはちょっと紹介したいと思います
まず「ヒートパイプ」という
熱を素早く伝える装置です
これは 毛細管現象を使っていて
仰々しい名前ですけども
要は色水に 綿をつなげる
そうしたら
ほっといたら 緑色の液ができる
これは綿で生まれた 毛細管力によって
水が引っ張り上げられる
こういう現象です
例えば 水の中にパイプを入れる
そしたら 引っ張り上げられる
これも それです
目が細い―
パイプが細ければ 細いほど
高い毛細管力が 生まれる
これがポイントです
そういったものはですね
その「ヒートパイプ」の中には
それが生まれるものが 入っていて
そこで 液が蒸発して
蒸気がまた 冷たいとこで液になって
液がまた引っ張り上げられる
ということを行う
これが 電気を使わないで液が動く
デバイスです
もう一つ 「熱電発電技術」
これはですね
温度差で電気が生まれる
温度差です
これ「ボイジャー」という衛星は
今から40年以上前に―
今も活動してるんですけども
つくられました
ここはですね
原子力が積まれていて
そこの高い温度と宇宙の低い温度
この二つの温度差で 電気を作り出して
それがメインの電源になっています
せっかくなんでここで
実験をしてみたいと思います
ここにあるのが 「熱電素子」です
ここにあるのが 「ヒートパイプ」という―
６本の これが
「ヒートパイプ」というものです
こちらにあるのが 熱いお湯
そしてこちらが 冷たい氷水
ここにですね
この「ヒートパイプ」を入れてみます
そうするとですね
「ヒートパイプ」というのは
熱を伝えます
そして ここで 電気が生まれて
一気に プロペラが回ります
これが「ヒートパイプ」と「熱電発電」による
発電というものです
（拍手）
はい こういう技術があります
そして 私は大学を卒業した後に
アメリカで研究をする
チャンスに恵まれます
それで 私は「ヒートパイプ」―
この熱輸送技術より
もっと凄いことを研究したい と思って
そこで出会ったのが
「ループヒートパイプ」という技術です
これは簡単に説明すると
さっきはただのパイプだったんですけども
それがぐるっと巻かれていて
ただのパイプです
それで 一箇所だけ 毛細管力を
生み出すところがあります
そこに 「多孔体」というものが
入れられていて―
「多孔体」って要するに
スポンジのようなものです
ただ目がものすごく細かくて
髪の毛の10分の１くらいの
目がいっぱいあいています
ですので ここに髪の毛が落ちていると
こんな感じで見えなくなっちゃいます
これぐらい細い目がいっぱいあいて
毛細管力をすごく高くしている
それがポイントです
せっかくですので
それも 実験してみたいと思います
これが 実験室でつくってきた
「ループヒートパイプ」というものです
ここにその毛細管現象を
生み出すとこがあって
ここはただのパイプですね
ここで熱を捨てるんですけども
ちょっと動くかな？
（ドライヤーの音）
ちょっと時間かかるかも
しれませんが
（ドライヤーの音）
どうでしょう
あ 動いた
見えますかね
ちょっと 見えにくいかもしれませんが
いらない熱を奪って 動き出す
（拍手）
はい
ちょっと下までいかなかったですけれども
「ループヒートパイプ」 というのは
今までの「ヒートパイプ」 よりも
長い距離運べます
そうすると　今まで人工衛星に積めた
電子機器よりも
もっと沢山の電子機器を
積み込めることが できます
つまり この 「ループヒートパイプ」
という技術は
人工衛星の高性能化には欠かせない
技術になってきています
さて 私は今まで宇宙のパッシブな
熱制御技術についてお話ししました
こういった技術は 我々の身近なところでは
役に立たないんでしょうか？
そんなことはありません
先ほどの「ヒートパイプ」
こちらは
すでに我々のパソコンや ノートパソコンにも
使われています
そして最近はこの
もっと薄くて小さいものが
スマートフォンにも
使われてきております
そしてさっきの熱電発電
それも今 世の中には
いろんな いらない熱があって
そこのいらない熱と空気
そして 熱と水 その温度差で
電気を取り出そうという研究が
活発に行われています
ちなみに なんですけれども
こちら これも 熱電発電ウォッチ といって
中に 熱電素子が 使われています
そして これは 私の体温と空気の温度差で
電気が生み出されて
この時計が動いています
そういうものまで できてきています
こういった技術があるんですが
例えば今 私が研究している
「ループヒートパイプ」
これを我々の生活に持ってきたら
どうことが起こるでしょう
今まで「ヒートパイプ」では
できなかったような距離を 熱が運びます
そうするとまた違った世界が
見えてくるかな と思います
では一体どれくらい運べるんだろう
と思うかもしれませんが
実験室で作ってみました
そうすると片道10メートル
全長28メートル
そういう「ループヒートパイプ」が
できました
片道10メートルというのは この舞台から
端から端ですね
だいたい10メートル
ここの間をですね
電気を使わずに いらない熱だけで
液体と気体がぐるぐる回る
そういうところまで
できるようになってきています
これができるようになると
例えば 自動車のエンジンの
廃熱を利用したり
あるいは 焼却炉の熱を取り出したり
あるいは 住宅のエネルギーシステム
こういいったものに組み込んで
いけるんじゃないかな と考えています
こちら 私が３年前に建てた家です
35年ローンです
(笑)
屋根には太陽電池パネルが載っていて
その横にですね
四角い こういったスペースがあります
これ何かというと
私のプライベートな
熱の実験スペースです
どこまで熱好きなんだよ と
思われるかもしれないですけれども
ここに太陽光を集めて
何か面白いことできないかな
と考えています
それで 今はここに
「ループヒートパイプ」をつけて
お湯を作ったり
そこで作った熱を 床暖房で使ったり
あるいは プロペラを回して電力を取り出す
そういったことができないかな
と考えています
この「ループヒートパイプ」は
電気を使わない
しかも ポンプもいらないので
壊れることもありません
そうすると 電気代 ガス代がいらない
お湯をつくるのに
それは もちろん35年ローンの
私のお財布にも 優しいですが
（笑）
本質的にはもっとすごいことがあって
地球に何よりも優しい
ということです
皆さん 今 世の中では
沢山 エネルギーが使われています
そのうちの８％は 何だと思いますか
我々が家で使っている
冷房　暖房　給湯
つまりこの家で使っている
熱エネルギー
これが全体のエネルギー消費の
８％を占めています
それを 今までよりも
太陽熱のような
今まで使われていなかった
熱を積極的に利用することで
そのエネルギー消費量を
削減することができます
そうすれば CO２の排出量の
削減にもつながる
そういった可能性があります
そして この「ループヒートパイプ」の
ポイントは
重力に逆らって 液体を持ち上げられる
ここがポイントです
ここ安城市では
今から100年以上前に
明治用水が敷かれた事を
ご存知だと思うんですけれど
市民の手で完成された と言われています
主流は約53キロ
その中 水は当然
重力に従って
高いところから低いところに流れています
しかし その高低差はわずか
10数メートルと言われています
そんな技術を
すでに 100年以上前に実現している
ものすごいことだなと思います
それに対して 私の技術は たかだか
10メートル 20メートルですけれども
ポイントはこの重力に逆らって
液体を持ち上げられる ということですね
毛細管力―
毛細管現象を使って
それを極限まで高めることで
それができるようになってくるんです
ここ数年のうちに これをフィールド実証して
世の中に提案したいな と考えています
ところで私は今も
火星移住計画を 夢見ているでしょうか
答えはNOです
技術的に難しいとか
コスト的に厳しいとか
そういったことではありません
地球に住めなくなったから 火星に行く
この発想自体に
疑問を持つようになったからです
地球に住めなくなったのは 誰のせいですか
自分のやったことを顧みず
地球を捨てて 火星に行くんですか と
そこが許し難いなと
今は思うようになってきています
自分のやったことに責任が持てない
そんな種は いっそ
滅んだほうがいいんじゃないだろうか
それぐらいに思っています
我々は地球に生まれたわけです
そして我々を育ててくれた地球
その負担をですね
少しでも軽くしてやることが
大事なんではないでしょうか
私は大学で 火星移住計画に憧れて
宇宙開発に飛び込みました
そこでパッシブな技術に出会って
「宇宙で生き延びるための技術」を
研究してきました
しかしそれは 地球にもってくれば
「地球で生き延びるための技術」として
大いに役に立てる
その可能性に気付くことができました
私は宇宙の熱屋として
そして パッシブな熱技術にこだわる身として
そして 何よりも
地球で生まれた一人の人間として
宇宙だけではなくて
地球にも優しい技術
そういったものを
作っていきたいと考えております
地球生まれ 地球育ちの我々が
地球のためにできること
やり方は色々あると思います
その中で熱―
熱というものを有効に利用する
大切にするだけでも
地球には優しいんだ
ということを
ぜひ知ってもらいたいと思います
そして今まで使われていなかった
無駄に捨てられていた熱
それを有効利用する
そのために一体
どういったことができるだろうか
皆さんと一緒に考えていけたらな
と思います
ありがとうございました
(拍手)